with three new episodes of the boys now
available to watch on amazon prime
and five to go season two promises to be
packed with references and nods that
might not stand out after a single
viewing
here are a few the boys enjoys its
television and movie references
whether it's a nod to other projects
that the cast and crew have worked on in
the past
or having chris hansen of to catch a
predator fame anchor a news broadcast
there are plenty of little things to
look out for in the opening scene of the
boy's first episode of the second season
the audience jumps back and forth
between two events
black noir cleaning up a mess from the
end of the previous season
and mr edgar negotiating the conditions
of vots superheroes operating in the
military
and the damage they might cause to human
life exactly what
casualty allowance are we looking at
here officially
zero of course but cone of silence 34
this is a reference to get smart a
comedic 1960s spy show starring don
adams as agent 86 in it a running gag
continually resurfaced around maxwell
smart's desire to speak to the chief
privately
urging for the highest level of secrecy
by using the cone of silence
a device consisting mostly of clear
plastic that would usually lower from
the ceiling and cover the heads of both
men so they could communicate without
fear of being heard
the device however rarely worked as
intended
about that whale one of the gorier
scenes in the series happens in the
third episode of the second season
when a confrontation on the high seas
turns into a sticky situation on the
beach
involving the deep and a whale inside
the messy mammal
huey has had enough and thinks the best
course of action is to give up
inside the beast refusing butcher's help
butcher decides to leave him can't leave
the king man
pinocchio stained pud fans of the boys
may not have seen
disney's 1940 classic animated film
pinocchio recently
but one of the later scenes involves a
handful of the characters
ending up trapped in the stomach of a
giant whale named monstro
in an effort to save his friends and
father figure pinocchio devises a plan
to make the sea creature sneeze so they
can escape
thankfully all huey has to do to leave
is crawl out of a giant
speedboat sized hole anyone who's read
the source
material for the boys doesn't need to be
told how terrible of a person black noir
is
the new season of the show reveals that
he isn't afraid to murder women
but will we see his other atrocities on
display during the series
in the first episode he's dispatched to
kill a super terrorist
and after doing so he walks into the
room of a small child while still
holding the severed head
this moment concerned some fans who were
in the know as black noir's comics
counterpart has been known to
cannibalize children on occasion but
here we see him pick up a stuffed bunny
and play with it for a moment
this version of the character made for
the small screen seems to be different
though
even touching his chest as if moved by
the sight of a dead whale
it's a quick moment easy to overlook and
it probably shouldn't be taken as a sign
that black noir
deserves to be seen as anything but an
antagonist and killer
but it may indicate a softer side to
this incarnation or at least the
showrunner's trying to give him some
more
personality every good superhero
franchise needs movies and when you're
in a world of real life heroes making
sure those movies are actually
good is probably even more important in
an episode 3 scene
we see someone pitching the script and
storyboards for an upcoming film to the
group
getting wrapped up in his own hype when
going over the final scene
and the big reveal of the ending where
he proudly proclaims
title card dawn of the seven cut to
black
the phrase itself might not be enough to
say that the boys
is nodding to the subtitle for batman vs
superman dawn of justice
but that isn't the only clue here at one
point the film promoter suggests
batman vs superman composer hans zimmer
when discussing the appropriate music
for the scene
and then there's also the color scheme
of the poster mocking up the film's logo
this is an even deeper cut than it looks
the original comics for the boys were
initially published by wildstorm
a subsidiary of dc comics before moving
over to dynamite entertainment
and don't worry that it's all about dc
here the boy's second season is also
off to a good start with its pot shots
at marvel like homelander making fun of
the idea of having a visually impaired
hero named blind spot
who is obviously pretty inspired by
daredevil
season 2 begins with the boys in a rough
spot not only are they hiding out
underneath the pawn shop is wanted
criminals but there's no butcher
and that means no leadership in his
absence hughie tries to get his
teammates to do things a bit differently
and entertain other ideas
but this doesn't seem to fly especially
when butcher returns with new
motivations
it isn't long before their personalities
clash and punches start flying between
the two
huey has always been a bit of a moral
center for the group and a member of the
team
even points this out in episode three
here's your canary
what canary you let your canary die
how you gonna know when you've gone too
far this is all fine
two headstrong people working through
their issues
but for those familiar with the comics
this initial physical confrontation is
also an
unpleasant foreshadowing without going
into major spoilers
the stories the show is based on see
butcher and huey experiencing
a much greater disagreement on what
needs to be done at the end of a long
and depressing road
with a lot of lives held in the balance
the two
wind up doing a little more than just
punching each other at that point
if the show follows suit this will be a
moment to look back on
and see where it started check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you